Tucker Carlson has been in the media
since the 1990s. He's been covering
politics the entire time. And yet, in a
recent podcast, he didn't know basic
facts about Hamas, which leads to some
obvious questions. How can a political
commentator be ignorant about Hamas? How
is he covering world politics all these
years without knowing what he was
talking about? Was he simply reading
what someone else had put on the
teleprompter for him without
understanding what he was reading? Is
Tucker Carlson Ron Burgundy?
>> From the entire Channel 4 News team, I'm
Veronica Corningstone.
>> And I'm Ron Burgundy. Go yourself, San
Diego.
Ah, the context of the clips we're about
to watch is that Tucker can't figure out
how. If this is a war against Hamas,
Christians are dying, too. The whole
justification for all this, you just
said it. These journalists get blown up,
they were Hamas. Okay, end of
conversation.
No one can plausibly claim that a
Christian family are in Hamas. Okay, so
like what? Tell me if you can't claim
that they're in Hamas while
simultaneously claiming that Hamas is uh
you know group of jihadis. They're
Islamic extremists which they also
claim. So the justification for taking
people out in Gaza is that they're part
of Hamas. But if Hamas is an Islamic
terrorist organization, there obviously
won't be Christians in Hamas. And yet
approximately 45 Christians have been
killed in Gaza since the war started.
Those Christians weren't members of
Hamas, so why are they dead? Seasoned
political commentator Tucker Carlson
still doesn't seem to understand the
tactic of using human shields. Hamas has
perfected the use of human shields. Keep
in mind, when we're talking about human
shields, we don't usually mean holding a
kid in front of you and using him as a
shield. We mean a group that kills a
bunch of people and takes a bunch of
hostages and then runs and plays hideand
seek around schools, hospitals,
churches. So that when their enemies
retaliate, when their enemies hunt down
the terrorists or come looking for their
hostages, they end up killing
non-combatants in the process. Hamas
specializes in putting people in this
position, a position where there's no
good outcome. I'll explain it in even
simpler terms for you Tucker fans who,
like Tucker, don't understand how this
leads to non-combatant deaths.
Suppose your kid is in school and
someone starts firing rockets at your
kids's school. Suppose you also have
rockets and you can make the man stop
firing rockets at your kid's school by
firing your rockets at him. The problem
is the guy who's firing rockets at your
kid's school is firing those rockets
from his kid's school.
What do you do? Do you just let him keep
firing rockets at your kids' school? Or
do you stop him by firing your rockets
at him, but destroy his kid's school in
the process? No matter what you decide
to do, there are bad consequences.
So, if a large terrorist group that
controls a large territory decides to
start a war, and this terrorist group
has perfected the art of using human
shields, guess what? A lot of
non-combatants are going to die. To be
clear, this is just the general
principle. This doesn't mean you can't
object to particular cases. You can
always say, "Hey, we know you're up
against a group that's trying to
maximize civilian casualties, and this
puts you in a nightmare situation, but
you still should have been more careful
and not fired in this case." That can be
a totally legitimate criticism. But
Tucker just can't figure out how any
Christians died at all. So, I'll just
say that if Hamas hadn't started the war
and if Hamas didn't use human shields as
their primary war tactic, those 45
Christians would be alive right now.
Back to Tucker for an even more shocking
display of complete ignorance. You can't
claim that they're in Hamas while
simultaneously claiming that Hamas is
uh, you know, group of jihadis. They're
Islamic extremists, which they also
claim constantly, which I don't I don't
know if that's true, by the way. Seems
more like a political organization, but
whatever it is, they're telling us
constantly they're al-Qaeda. So, it
can't also be true that Christians are
member of al-Qaeda. Sorry.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, Tucker is again wondering if the
justification for killing Hamas members
is that they're jihadis, how are people
who aren't members of Hamas getting
killed? We've discussed that. But notice
that Tucker said he's not sure that
Hamas members are jihadis or Islamic
extremists. They're Islamic extremists,
which they also claim constantly, which
I don't I don't know if that's true. By
the way,
>> critics claim that Hamas members are
jihadis or Islamic extremists.
>> You can't claim that they're in Hamas
while simultaneously claiming that Hamas
is,
you know, group of jihadis. They're
Islamic extremists, which they also
claim.
>> But Tucker isn't sure about that.
>> I don't I don't know if that's true, by
the way.
>> He thinks Hamas seems more like a
political organization.
>> Seems more like a political
organization, but whatever it is,
they're telling us constantly they're
al-Qaeda. So, it can't also be true that
Christians are member of al-Qaeda.
Sorry.
>> So, veteran political commentator Tucker
Carlson is not only ignorant about
Hamas, he's also ignorant about Islam.
Islam is inherently political. It calls
for the subjugation of the entire world
under the leadership of an Islamic
caiff. But we'll have to explain that to
Tucker another time because I want to
focus on Tucker's sneaking suspicion
that Hamas isn't a group of jihadis or
Islamic extremists.
>> You can't claim that they're in Hamas
while simultaneously claiming that Hamas
is,
you know, group of jihadis. They're
Islamic extremists, which they also
claim constantly, which I don't I don't
know if that's true. By the way,
>> let's start with the name. Hamas is an
abbreviation for Harakat Amukawa
al-Islamia, which means Islamic
Resistance Movement. So, they literally
put it in the name of their group. But
you Tucker fans might object. Come on,
David. Just because someone puts Islamic
in the name of their group doesn't mean
they're really Islamic. If Tucker says
they don't sound like jihadis or Islamic
extremists to him, that's good enough
for us. Okay, why don't we take a quick
peek at their founding charter,
the Covenant of the Islamic Resistance
Movement, 18 August 1988.
in the name of the most merciful Allah.
And they begin with a long quotation
from surah 3 of the Quran. Ye Muslims
are the best nation that hath been
raised up unto mankind. Ye command that
which is just, and ye forbid that which
is unjust, and ye believe in Allah. And
if they who have received the
scriptures, Jews and Christians, had
believed, it had surely been the better
for them. There are believers among
them, but the greater part of them are
transgressors. Most Jews and Christians
are transgressors.
They shall not hurt you unless with a
slight hurt. And if they fight against
you, they shall turn their backs to you,
and they shall not be helped. They are
smitten with vileeness wheresoever they
are found unless they obtain security by
entering into a treaty with Allah and a
treaty with men. And they draw on
themselves indignation from Allah and
they are afflicted with poverty. Poor
Jews and Christians. This they suffer
because they disbelieved the signs of
Allah and slew the prophets unjustly.
This because they were rebellious and
transgressed. Surah al- Imran verses 109
to 111. Israel will exist and will
continue to exist until Islam will
obliterate it just as it obliterated
others before it. Lovely quote from the
martyr Imam Hassan Albana of blessed
memory.
Imam Hassan Albana was the founder of
the Muslim Brotherhood. More on the
Muslim Brotherhood in a moment.
Sounds pretty Islamic so far, but Tucker
just isn't convinced. He knows Hamas
better than they know themselves. But
maybe we should let Hamas define their
own movement. Oh, here we go. They did
define their own movement. Definition of
the movement. Ideological starting
points. Article one. The Islamic
Resistance Movement. The movement's
program is Islam. From it from Islam it
draws its ideas, ways of thinking and
understanding of the universe, life and
man. It resorts to it Islam for judgment
in all its conduct and it is inspired by
it for guidance of its steps. Where does
the Islamic resistance movement get its
ideas? From Islam. The Islamic
resistance movement's relation with the
Muslim Brotherhood group. Article two.
The Islamic Resistance Movement is one
of the wings of Muslim Brotherhood in
Palestine. Muslim Brotherhood movement
is a universal organization which
constitutes the largest Islamic movement
in modern times. It is characterized by
its deep understanding, accurate
comprehension, and its complete embrace
of all Islamic concepts of all aspects
of life, culture, creed, politics,
economics, education, society, justice,
and judgment, the spreading of Islam,
education, art, information, science of
the occult, and conversion to Islam.
And as a wing of the Muslim Brotherhood,
Hamas is striving not only for the
extermination of Jews, but also for the
return of the Islamic Caiphate. Don't
take my word for it. Here's a Hamas
leader.
[Music]
Does this sound like some sort of
secular political movement?
>> I don't I don't know if that's true by
the way. Seems more like a political
organization.
>> Structure and formation. Article three.
The basic structure of the Islamic
resistance movement consists of Muslims
who have given their allegiance to Allah
whom they truly worship. I have created
the jin and humans only for the purpose
of worshiping who know their duty
towards themselves, their families and
country. In all that they fear Allah and
raise the banner of jihad in the face of
the oppressors so that they would rid
the land and the people of their
uncleanliness, vileeness and evils. They
fear Allah and raise the banner of
jihad. And what's the goal? The Islamic
resistance movement aspires to the
realization of Allah's promise, no
matter how long that should take. The
prophet Allah bless him and grant him
salvation has said the day of judgment
will not come about until Muslims fight
the Jews killing the Jews. When the Jew
will hide behind stones and trees, the
stones and trees will say, "Oh Muslims,
oh Abdullah, there is a Jew behind me.
Come and kill him." Only the gared tree,
evidently a certain kind of tree, would
not do that because it is one of the
trees of the Jews. Related by Albukari
and Muslim. Let's see if they're quoting
Muhammad accurately. Sah Muslim, the
messenger of Allah said, "The hour will
not begin until the Muslims fight the
Jews, and the Muslims will kill them.
Until a Jew hides behind a rock or a
tree, and the rock or tree will say, "Oh
Muslim, oh slave of Allah, there is a
Jew behind me. Come and kill him."
Except the gar, a thorny tree, for it is
one of the trees of the Jews.
snitch. He stands with his crew shade in
the heat when they're coming for you.
>> So Hamas wants their enemies dead, but
they also want themselves dead. The
slogan of the Islamic Resistance
Movement, Article 8. Allah is its
target, the prophet is its model, the
Quran its constitution, jihad is its
path, and death for the sake of Allah is
the loftiest of its wishes.
Notice Hamas jihadis have pledged to
fulfill Muhammad's prophecy that Muslims
will exterminate Jews. Not just
Zionists, Jews. But Hamas jihadis also
say that death for the sake of Allah is
the loftiest of their wishes.
So they want their enemies dead to
fulfill Muhammad's prophecy and they
want themselves dead because the
greatest thing you can do in Islam is
die while waging jihad.
They want their enemies dead and
themselves dead. This is a death cult.
And yet we have seasoned political
commentators who've been discussing
global politics for decades suggesting
that these guys may not be jihadis or
Islamic extremists at all.
>> You can't claim that they're in Hamas
while simultaneously claiming that Hamas
is uh you know group of jihadis. They're
Islamic extremists which they also claim
constantly which I don't I don't know if
that's true by the way. seems more like
a political organization, but whatever
it is, they're telling us constantly
they're al-Qaeda.
>> Why is this a problem? Well, we've got
political commentators who've been
building up massive followings for years
or even decades, spouting idiotic
nonsense, and their followers trust
them.
This is dangerous. Hamas is a death
cult. Egypt shares a border with Gaza.
This is Egypt's border with Gaza. Egypt
knows they're dealing with a death cult.
Other Muslim nations know they're
dealing with a death cult. Who still
doesn't understand that Hamas is a death
cult? Tucker Carlson, Tucker's fans,
lots of Western governments, lots of
Western journalists, educators and
entertainers.
Imagine journalists and politicians
thinking that Hamas jihadis are the good
guys. Maybe they're not jihadis. Maybe
they're just religiously pluralistic
freedom fighters.
When it comes to jihad, willful
ignorance gets people killed.
But not me, because I know the one place
jihadis can never find me.
[Music]
He stands with his crew. Shade in the
heat when they're coming for you. Every
rock's whispering, every bush going to
squeal. But Gaga in the shade, keeping
secrets sealed.